[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nothing comes easy here
in our wildest frontier
home to some of the deadliest animals on
the planet
this
is alaska
and you need true grit to live here
north america doesn't get much colder
nor any darker than alaska in winter
the only way to survive here is to go
wild
this is a dangerous time of year
it's the end of winter
competition for food is at its peak
this year's late arrival of spring
heightens the tension
the hungry grow weaker
a golden eagle watches stellar sea
eagles arriving on his patch
[Music]
they're not here to hunt
they're here to steal
but a squabble breaks out within their
gang
an opportunity for the golden eagle to
win his food back
he's the bigger bird
and he's fully loaded with razor-sharp
talons
talons that lock in the featherweight
food fight
[Music]
the battle rages
[Music]
until the proud owner of this patch
wins it back
[Music]
here in alaska
only the toughest bird survives
after months of punishing cold it
happens
light breaks through the biggest sky in
america
warmth finally loosens winter's tight
grip
awakening new hungers
alaska's north gets as many as 40
additional minutes of light every day
until
there's no night at all
[Music]
streams and rivers swell with melted ice
and snow
animals that have struggled in winter
now look for quick and easy meals
brought by spring's abundance
[Music]
but this is
alaska where nothing is easy
crabs lingering just below the tidal
mark look like a trouble-free lunch
for a mink
the mink is a specialized crab hunter
his teeth can easily crush shell
so
[Music]
[Music]
but the mink may have met his match with
this large dungeness crab
[Music]
[Music]
in alaska sometimes the prey bites back
or
pinches
so the mink has to get creative
taking out the enemy's defenses
limb by limb
[Music]
even if the mink chews off all the legs
the crab might live
legs grow back
[Music]
top predators have a reputation for
making lunch look easy
but they must contend with brilliant
defenses conjured by set lunch
[Music]
exhibit a
a 20 pound porcupine
[Music]
slow subdued
no doubt tasty
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
but how to get by those nearly 30 000
quills
[Music]
what the prey lacks in speed it makes up
for in defense
[Music]
each bacterium-filled quill can pierce
the wolf's skin like a hypodermic needle
and cause major infection
a sharp reminder in these parts
no meal is an easy meal
the hunter decides the danger far
outweighs the reward
and moves on to something uh
easier to swallow
[Music]
[Music]
the now constant sunlight triggers
tremendous growth
the fertile grasses beckon great herds
of caribou here from colder canadian
plains
a single herd can hold more than 120 000
caribou
during their annual migration
they'll cover more than three thousand
miles
their babies are often born on the move
and need to keep up with the herd
one separated from the pack is a target
this calf has lost her way
just what the nearby hunters are banking
on
[Music]
so
[Music]
the calf escapes this time
but another predator awaits
more insidious and harder to shake
perhaps the deadliest animal of all
[Music]
alaska is known for its jaws paws and
claws
but its smallest critter may be the
biggest menace
the mosquito
more than 35 species feast in the
endless daylight
these mini monsters lay dormant all
winter as eggs
now the tundra underfoot turns to water
triggering a mass hatching
just as caribou shed their winter coats
they attack
if infection sets in it could easily
kill a baby caribou
the mosquitoes then feast on festering
wounds
entire herds will re-root their
migration just to avoid the mosquito
menace
[Music]
this group hugs the ocean
and looks for a sea breeze to blow the
buzzing from their backs
there's little relief even standing in
the arctic ocean
[Music]
never has such a deadly creature been
just so annoying
[Music]
there's nothing left to do but plunge
into a full body bath
which seems to do the trick
no animal is immune to its blood-sucking
attacks
and as quickly as they appeared
they vanish
[Music]
plentiful water brings a different kind
of horde to alaska
the streams and rivers swell with melted
ice and snow
by late spring the waterways gush
sockeye salmon arrive from the pacific
over 30 million of them
swimming upriver to spawn in the very
place they were born
of the thousands that arrive only a few
make it back
they've got a lot of obstacles on their
way up
dams
disease
fishermen
but the last thing they want to
encounter is
this guy
the brown bear the ultimate predator
adult males sport four-inch
non-retractable claws that can slash
with precision
they have three inch canine teeth
that grasp and tear flesh
brown bears are among the strongest
creatures on earth
and strength needs fuel
[Music]
lots of it
after months of slim pickings it's time
for a fish feast
these bears need a protein boost fast
this is where rank in brown bear
hierarchy matters most
a rocky outcrop midway across is one of
the best fishing positions on the river
control of this perch gives its owner a
critical advantage
here fishing requires virtually no
effort
[Music]
it's possible to pack on pounds and save
energy
at the same time
[Music]
downstream a mother bear and her cubs
approach the good spot
the growing cubs need the protein
but this is a dangerous place for them
aggressive males can injure or even kill
them
the swift current separates the mother
from her young
[Music]
an older male seizes his opportunity
and attacks
he could easily slaughter the cubs
but mother steps in
at this moment she may be the most
dangerous bear in alaska
the older male outweighs her by 500
pounds
but he knows not to mess with a mother's
fury
and he has more important things to
worry about
like maintaining his position
above the falls
during the fight the older male lost his
prized fishing spot
young challengers have seized the
opportunity and moved in on his turf
[Music]
so
now the balance of power teeters above
the falls
the older bear has more experience but
is weakened by his fighting
this younger stronger rival seizes his
chance to oust the older bear
so
[Music]
[Music]
the fallen king is chased further
downstream
[Music]
a loss of rank could mean the loss of
life
especially during the salmon run
when the window of opportunity will soon
abruptly shut
such is the hardship for alaskan
predators whose warm weather bounty
lasts but a blink of an eye
the arctic fox is looking forward to
summer however brief
his icy wasteland transforms into a land
of possibilities
[Music]
all requiring stealth
step one
a new wardrobe
get rid of the white winter fur coat to
match the new terrain
now
he's an expert at hiding in plain sight
the goal is to catch most of the year's
prey in a very short window of time
it will make or break
him suddenly a feast arrives
millions of migratory birds turn his
island into an easter basket
one lost egg tastes good
[Music]
imagine a whole nest
but getting at the mother lode can be
tricky
because of well
mothers
and fathers
[Music]
arctic turns are fearless parents
these birds can draw blood
[Music]
and they'll even peck out his eyes
[Music]
the arctic fox dodges his attackers
but he still needs to meet a huge quota
of prey
[Music]
he's hunting for six
so he avoids the vigilantly protected
nest altogether
and goes right for the chick
a bird in the mouth is worth at least a
dozen eggs
another predator that stalks these
barren lands is a hundred times larger
than the fox
with an appetite to match
and unlike her brown bear cousins polar
bears don't hibernate
they hunt year-round
[Music]
in winter polar bears eat seals that
live on the ice
but come spring
they are nowhere to be found
so she must go far and wide to find
something to eat
a polar bear search for food is even
harder in a warming climate
the farther she must swim
the hungrier she gets
a lucky break for the polar bear
the sea has done her work for her
a washed up whale carcass
it's an amazing sight
27 tons of blubber
[Music]
it's an all-you-can-eat blubber buffet
and her first bite of substantial food
in months
amazingly it could feed her for a whole
year
but that's if she has it to herself
other ice bears have the same idea
[Music]
the small bears are enthusiastic
they're still nursing but also need
their fill of fat
[Music]
and suddenly a huge male appears
his hunger is as big as his bark
a smaller mother bear isn't happy about
the intrusion
and tries to teach him a lesson
[Music]
hmm
he sneaks in from another angle
but he's told to wait his turn
once the others have had their fill the
male is finally given permission to lick
the fat
after months of summer the sunshine is
no longer endless
and chilly misty mornings mark the
arrival of autumn
and the return of giants
[Music]
a moose bull in his prime shows off his
splendid antlers
[Music]
he jousts loudly with vegetation for the
benefit of cows and fellow bulls alike
the biggest racks actually make a
different sound than the smaller ones
announcing size and status to anyone who
might be listening
the females take notice
other bulls entering their prime and
bearing equally impressive headgear are
drawn to the scent of the cows
the stage is awash in testosterone
and trouble can't be far behind
the bulls are ready to rumble
[Music]
with the rut in full swing
a come hither look from a moose cow
brings the dominant bull running
the females are getting more and more
receptive showing their approval of the
big bull status by contributing their
pheromone-laden urine to his rut pits
[Music]
with his exquisitely sensitive nose he
checks on a cow's readiness
[Music]
he seems pleased with the results
at 11 years old he is truly a picture of
a bull in his prime
1500 pounds seven feet high at the
shoulder
with a six-foot rack
it's no wonder the cows like what they
see
but there's trouble on the horizon
a younger and equally impressive bull
the challenger approaches
waving his great antlers from side to
side
the master responds
these rituals of intimidation are
usually enough to determine who will
dominate
thus avoiding the risk of injury in a
fight
the females have a keen interest in the
outcome
like prize fighters they stare each
other down
circle
and wait for an opening
neither is backing down
with equally matched goals the battle
may last up to a half an hour or more
[Music]
but the older bull soon gains the upper
hand
he batters the challenger unmercifully
abruptly
the contest is decided
the master will return to his harem
the younger one paid the price for his
bid to reproduce
in this unforgiving place
his wounded leg may spell doom
the victor has urgent business to tend
to
and just in time
fall
is on the way out
[Music]
winter comes early this year
[Music]
record snowfall gives deep cover for
rodents
like the vole
[Music]
hidden beneath they're protected from
the cold and hunters above
[Music]
the vole's ears are big and can listen
out for danger
but what good is that if danger
makes no sound
silence is the snowy owl secret weapon
[Music]
fringed edges of her flight feathers
break up the flapping noise that a
normal bird makes
[Music]
and her attack
is as silent as death
the vole never knew what hit him
[Music]
snow is a problem for predator and prey
alike
mostly because it makes sound
[Music]
but alaska's creatures have come up with
ingenious workarounds
the red fox has perfected the hunt below
and above
[Music]
at only 10 pounds he doesn't break the
snow surface
[Music]
so he can search for prey
without detection
[Music]
but his prey
hides below the surface
so how do you find what you cannot see
big ears
and magnetic senses
sync together these secret weapons make
the red fox a stealth hunter
able to catch his victims under nearly
two feet of snow
first he pinpoints the faintest sound
then hones in on the sweet spot
where the angle of the sound matches the
slope of the planet's magnetic field
once the fox locks onto that spot
he can calculate the exact distance to
his prey
in this case
a metal bowl
but then what
if he digs
the vole will flee
so instead
he flies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a small bite
[Music]
but in winter every calorie counts
alaska snows inspire a million ways for
hunters to innovate
one of those ways is to stop hunting
altogether
and start scavenging
the wolverine's nose leads the way
sniffing out prey and hibernating
animals buried more than 20 feet beneath
the snow
[Music]
this dog-sized weasel is able to take
down a full-grown caribou
but today this wolverine is saving his
energy
he's found a frozen dinner
it takes the keenest nose to pick up the
scent of a carcass in winter
wolverines outmatch most other animals
with this skill
but then they have to contend with each
other
within minutes
the competition arrives
this is when the true wolverine nature
kicks into the max
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the semi-retractable claws come out
the specialized teeth are bared
it's all-out war
the defender gets the upper claw
[Music]
and wins his meal back
powerful jaws break down the entire
animal
including hooves teeth
and bones
this is his turf
and his food
food that was supposed to be convenient
but this is deadly alaska
where the challenges are epic
animals like the wolverine don't just
survive the tough environment
they thrive
because of it
[Music]
you